let's imagine ourselves in some type of
a strange casino with very strange games
and you walk up to a table and on that
table there is an empty bag and the guy
who runs the table says look I've got
some marbles here three green marbles -
orange marbles and I'm going to stick
them in the bag and he literally sticks
them into the empty bag to show you
there's truly three green marbles
three green marbles and two orange
marbles - orange marbles and he says the
game that I want you to play or that if
you if you choose to play is you're
going to look away stick your hand in
this bag the bag is not transparent feel
around the marbles all the marbles feel
exactly the same and if you're able to
pick two green marbles if you're able to
take one marble out of the bag it's
green you put it down on the table then
put your hand back in the bag and take
another marble and if that one's also
green then you're going to win the prize
you're going to win the prize of you're
going to win win $1 if you get 2 greens
if you get 2 greens you're going to win
$1 we said well this sounds like an
interesting game how much does it cost
to play and the guy tells you it is 35
cents 35 cents to play so obviously
fairly low stakes casino so my question
to you is would you want to play this
game and don't put you know the fun
factor into it just economically does it
make sense for you to actually play this
game well let's think through the
probabilities a little bit so first of
all what's the probability that the
first marble you pick is green what's
the probability that first marble first
marble is green actually let me just
write first green probability first
green first green well the total
possible outcomes there's five marbles
here all equally likely so there's five
possible outcomes three of them satisfy
your event that the first is green so
there's a 3/5 probability that the first
is green so you have a thirty fifth
chance 3/5 probability I should say that
on that after that
you're kind of still in the game
now what's the problem that we what we
really care about is your probability of
winning the game you want the first to
be green and the second green well let's
think about this a little bit what is
the probability that the first is green
first I'll just write G for green and
and the second and the second is green
now you might be tempted to say oh well
maybe the second being green is the same
probability it's 3/5 I can just multiply
3/5 times 3/5 and I'll get 9 over 25
seems like a pretty straightforward
thing but the realization here is what
you do with that first green marble you
don't take that first green marble out
look at it and put it back in the bag so
when that you take that second pick the
number of green marbles that are in the
bag depends on what you got on the first
pick remember we take the marble out if
it's a green marble whatever marble it
is at whatever after the first pick we
leave it on the table we are not
replacing it so there's not any
replacement here so these are not
independent events let me make this
clear not independent not or in
particular the second pick the second
pick is dependent on the first dependent
dependent on the first on the first pick
if the first pick is green then you
don't have three green marbles in a bag
of 5 if the first pick is green you now
have two green marbles in a bag of four
so the way that we would refer to this
the probability of both of these
happening yes it's definitely equal to
the probability of the first green for
the probability of the first green times
times now this is kind of the new idea
the probability of the second green
second green given this little line
right over here just a straight up
vertical line just means given given
this means given given that the first
was green now what is the probability
that the second marble is green given
that the first marble was Green
well we draw through the
scenario right over here if the first
marble is green there are four possible
outcomes not five anymore and two of
them satisfy your criteria so two of
them satisfy your criteria so the
probability of the first marble green
being green and the second marble marble
being green is going to be the
probability that your first is green so
it's going to be 3/5 times the
probability that the second is green
given that the first was green now you
have one less marble in the bag and
we're assuming that the first pick was
green so you only have two marble to
green marbles left and so what does this
give us for our total probability well
let's see 3/5 times 2 4 it's well 2/4 is
the same thing as 1/2 this is going to
be equal to 3/5 times 1/2 which is equal
to 3 tenths or we could write that as
zero point three zero or we could say
there's a 30% 30% chance of picking two
green marbles when we are not replacing
so given that let me ask you the
question again would you want to play
this game well if you played this game
many many many many many times on
average you have a 30% chance 30% chance
of winning of winning $1 and we haven't
covered this yet but so your expected
value is really going to be 30% times $1
this gives you a little bit of a preview
which is going to be 30 cents 30 cents
30% chance of winning $1 you would
expect on average if you play this many
many many times that playing the game is
going to give you 30 cents now would you
want to give someone 35 cents to get
some to get on average 30 cents no you
would not want to play this game now one
thing I will let you think about is
would you want to play this game if you
could replace the green marble the first
pick after the first pick if you could
replace the green marble would you want
to pick would you want to play the game
in that scenario